thank you and thank you for inviting me
it's a real treat to be here this is a
little out I think let's lower that down
a bit everybody can hear me still just
fine all right great so a couple of
things quickly first of all I know
things about stuff so feel free to ask
questions and again you guys have
already sent in some questions by email
I look forward to answering those during
our sort of panel discussion comment
write a second point is we certainly
need more work in this area so thank you
for being here we're going to need this
is an all-hands-on-deck exercise nobody
gets a free pass on this so and because
it is economy-wide because it is global
in nature there is ultimately money to
be made in all this and so thinking
about the engineering and thinking about
the Entrepreneurship matters let me
dwell on that for just a second I
learned a couple of things in Washington
one of the things that I learned is that
the government is effectively run by
lawyers that's not true in every country
but it is true in our country one of the
things this means is that they actually
don't understand a lot of what is
material in this space they their
experience has been one where rhetoric
wins the day if you're talking about
civil rights if you're talking about
education if you're talking about a you
know civil justice if you're talking
about a lot of where these people are
training what they do international
affairs and so forth rhetoric is
actually the thing that wins in energy
and environment it's different you have
physics you have chemistry you have
engineering you have cost your big
active markets one of the things this
means is that they are hungry for input
they really are they want good feed and
two it also means they're really
reluctant to make policy in the space
because they're worried about making bad
policy so actually knowing things about
the engineering knowing things about the
finances knowing things about the market
is extremely helpful second thing I
learned in Washington this is also very
very important the United States
government does not make policy in other
countries this seems obvious and yet
i'll tell you i can't tell you the
number of conversation
I've had where people like well we just
got to make China do this so freely but
we're just gonna make India do this you
know last time I checked we had no
jurisdiction over India or China or any
other country we can't we can't
typically get you know Canada or
Australia to do something much less you
know other major countries around the
world and so we really have to be
clear-eyed about what what we're talking
about what's involved with that let me
start with just a couple of slides I
brought a bunch of presentations and I
brought a bunch of slides basically
because I didn't know quite what to
expect but this is a good way to start
this is a helpful way to think about it
just came back from 10 days in Australia
talking about a bunch of stuff and this
is one of the talks i gave about the
global clean energy mix my hope today is
to do two things one separate sense from
nonsense and to give you guys some good
ideas beyond that if i can do those
things then i'll consider myself a
successful so its first of all talk
about the actual climate just you know I
won't dwell on this because you all are
become pre-sold but the bottom line is
it's real it's human it man-made and
it's bad and the more work that gets
done on the Intergovernmental Panel on
Climate Change all they say is it keeps
getting worse than our understanding is
more robust and our uncertainty bands
are smaller but basically like the
central's thesis doesn't change climate
change is largely man-made it's bad and
it's real and so we've got a heat index
of 160 degrees in Iran this past year
that's not good we've got Zika and
malaria and other you know mosquito
borne pathogens widening their impact
zones that's bad we got massive
wildfires all around the world in
Indonesia and Australia this one's from
Candida fort mcmurray where we've not
only had sort of record heat and drought
but also we had a pine beetle
devastation of the forest which is trash
light ecosystem and of course here in
California we got into water this is a
persistent issue and will continue to be
an issue and water scarce issues
water-scarce regions have been
particularly impacted by this but
are also more water scarcity in more
regions and those that are wire scarce
are having more urgency and a acuteness
around it so it's a big deal so this is
true great moving on this is also true
we've never used less of any kind of
energy ever and in fact we're going to
use an additional fifty percent more
than this over the next 30 to 35 years
or so so by 2050 there's going to be a
forty to sixty percent projected
increase in energy demand okay worldwide
yes and I'll talk about the u.s. in a
minute and this is also true you know
you don't get to walk away from this
people are talking about peak
consumption happen now guess what that's
peak per capita consumption maybe and so
in point of fact as long as this
population grow up with an economic
growth we're going to keep having energy
growth for a while still and I'll show
you some other numbers to back this up
this is material because this is what
that actually means it means we're
emitting 36 billion tons of carbon
dioxide a year today let me tell you a
couple of things that are relevant
around that one if all energy growth was
met with zero emission energy sources
worldwide we would still be emitting 36
billion tons a year when you deploy a
new nuclear plant or a new renewable
plant you don't actually reduce
emissions you avoid growth that's
important it's a good thing but that's
not the same thing as reducing emissions
okay only three things reduce emissions
efficiency and conservation carbon
capture and storage shutting down plants
that's it that's the full list so you
know this matters to give you a sense
most people don't really have an
understanding of a billion tons you
don't go to the store and buy a billion
tons of carrots so let me tell you what
a billion tons is a billion tons is
twice the weight of all the human beings
on earth we emit 75 times the mass of
humanity in the form of carbon dioxide
every year that also means that changing
light bulbs ain't going to do it either
you just got to do more it's a huge huge
huge difficult task
that doesn't change the work the fact
that it's huge and hard doesn't change
the fact that you have to do it but it
gives you a sense of what the job is
almost everybody who's looked at this
seriously comes up with the same
conclusion you need all of the above all
the above is not a bumper sticker it's
actually the right economics and
engineering part of the reason why and
this is really simple and I don't
understand why people don't talk about
it more frequently what this is is
what's called a general equilibrium
model this is from every but it works
for the International Energy Agency it
works for Stanford the energy modeling
forum here at Stanford aggregates all of
these models from around the world looks
at them if you look at each one of these
models there's a very robust finding and
that's that you need all of the above
and the reason why is it's pretty
obvious some solution will be the
cheapest solution in that market if you
take that off the table you have to
replace it with a more expensive option
no mystery actually in some market one
answer will be the cheapest thing in
another market it won't and so in that
context you need all of the above to do
the job and these are very common
numbers you typically ate a big helping
of end-use efficiency and demand
destruction that's a kind of a good
number you're always looking at kind of
the forty percent of the job not one
hundred percent of the job at forty
percent of the job it's a lot nuclear
always has a slice carbon capture and
storage always has a slice these are
kind of typical numbers nucleus sort of
six to ten percent CCS is typically
twelve to twenty percent you usually
have a bunch of renewables in there and
usually have some fuel switching you
stop using coal and start using gas you
stop using coal or gas and start using
biomass or something else you do some
fuel switching but this is a pretty good
mix one of the things this means though
if you take any option off the table
you're committing yourself to more costs
for no reason so at least one clever
person in the world understood this
pretty well and he put this at the
center of the climate action plan and he
basically said we're going to pursue an
all-of-the-above strategy for our nation
and that all of the above strategy is
going to have three primary planks we're
going to reduce emissions mitigate
deploy a bunch of clean energy
technologies all over the place to
adaptation climate change is real we've
already done a certain amount of it
ain't going away anytime soon we have to
heart and the infrastructure we have to
build resilience into the system we have
to get on with adaptation whether we
like it or not because it's real in the
third part is international he basically
said co2 doesn't stop on our boundaries
doesn't stop at anybody else's
boundaries either we have to have a
global Confederacy to get this to work
and the good news is he did and I know a
handful of the people who helped pull
this off but we got it I can't
underscore how important Paris is to all
of this discussion I really can't Paris
did two things one it fundamentally
changed the business model of climate
negotiations the previous model for
climate negotiations was a circular
firing squad was everybody pointing guns
at each other okay not a great way to
build an international Accord Paris was
completely different business model it
was a weight loss club everybody said
I'm going to lose 10 pounds that's what
Paris is we've got good firm targets out
of that two degrees and one and a half
degrees and that's relative to
pre-industrial baseline signed after the
UN it's now entered into force as of
Friday I think on Friday the Paris
Accords enter into full force thankfully
right before Marrakech before cop 22
starts it's worth knowing this numbers
already gone up to i think 86 now this
morning saudi arabia signed on you don't
think that's a big deal it is saudi
arabia is part of a global climate
Accord that's good it's also worth
knowing that that's actually not really
enough the fact that's not quite enough
is an understatement it's not close to
enough first of all a lot of the goals
that were set forth by countries were
contingent on funds they said we'll do
this if the money shows up so what the
what we actually do is to be determined
second if everybody does everything
including the contingent goals we're not
on a two degree trajectory we're on 2.7
degree trajectory we're basically
shootin to flatten out by the end of the
century maybe a little less that's a
good thing to do can't confuse that with
one and a half degrees or two degrees
you just can't confuse it with
things it's also voluntary so binding
and coming into full force for voluntary
accord we don't actually know what that
means this is still good one of the
things it means is that there's no
shelter anywhere there's no place in the
world you can go and imagine that carbon
constraints aren't coming your way it
also means that politicians are bound by
it people campaigned on to people you
know brought it to their countries and
said we have the best plan for our
country and we told the world we're
going to do you can't then say and now
we're not going to do it because you
can't you can't say it's not good for
our country you can't say we didn't make
the commitment so if there's a lot of
stuff that's really great about this but
its material important to understand
what this means another whack at what
this actually means in terms of the math
is represented by this this is bp's
number but again same thing for the
International Energy Agency almost
anybody who looks at these numbers has
very similar numbers this is what
innovation as usual looks like this is
what Paris looks like this is what a
bunch of good policy looks like it means
we're still screwed I can't be generous
about this if you basically look to 2015
and you look at all of the clean energy
growth we have that and you look at the
reduction in gap gas and coal and oil if
by 2050 our emissions are flat with
respect to today with a bunch of
emissions going up in between now and
then when I tell people these days and
you see it in the slide later if I get
to it if you believe in climate science
believe in climate math the math is
harsh it's unforgiving it's arithmetic
it ain't that hard there's no place to
hide the numbers are true we admit what
we emit and will continue to emit unless
there's a change one more stark detail
about this is that people have gotten
onto the idea that if you're going to
hit either a two degree target or a one
and a half degree target represented
respectively by the green in the blue
bands you need- emissions technology and
you don't need a bit of it you need a
bunch of it by the time that you really
need that stuff say for one and a half
degrees by 2050 you have to be pulling
10 billion tons out of the air every
year that's 20 times the mass of
humanity you have to be pulling out as
much out of the air as we are emitting
in the whole power sector worldwide
today Harshman forgiving numbers and we
don't actually have negative emissions
technologies these things don't exist
really we'll talk about that later I'm
happy to feel that question but we
functionally don't have it one last word
on the math and then we're going to get
talked about money for a minute after
that so the math most people don't see
it this way most people think about this
as well just fixed our this is actually
where global emissions come from about a
quarter of it comes from power that's a
big chunk about a quarter of it comes
from agriculture and land use okay about
a quarter of it comes from industry
should actually fifth a bunch comes from
transportation and buildings it's worth
knowing that both of those fractions are
growing but this is the actual math now
I said 36 billion tons of co2 we had
admit other greenhouse gases so we
actually emit 54 billion tons of
equivalent and we're basically to make
the math easier I said let's talk 40
giga tons of just the co2 forget the
other stuff this is just the co2
emissions in those points now let's say
that miraculously and I do mean
miraculously by 2050 you manage to zero
out both power and transportation and
buildings you get all of those 20
somehow let me say we're not going to
and we don't actually know how to but
let's say that you could it's not zero
known as it not zero it's not close to
zero it's still 20 billion tons this
ain't easy it's not the sort of thing
you can just declare it's not the sort
of thing that just happens and this
doesn't include non co2 greenhouse gases
or the fact that when China and India
clean up their air and pull the aerosols
out of it the cooling those aerosols
have been providing goes away right so a
couple of weeks ago we had the Montreal
Protocol we amended
we're going to have zero out hfcs that
is a huge big deal they're like I can't
understate how huge a big that deal is
it that doesn't change this math because
that math assumed that we were going to
get 20 on all that other stuff it assume
we got 20 on methane assume I got 20 and
sulfur hexafluoride resume we got 20 and
hfcs and Knox okay this is just the co2
this is why it's hard actually so now
let's talk about money to make it easy
I'm just going to talk about the power
sector for a while because the power
sector are things that kind of people
touch most people actually don't touch
agriculture in their day-to-day most
people don't touch steelmaking or cement
making in their day-to-day most
everybody touches power all right you
know maybe not see a power plant but
most people know what power plants are
they know what a windmill is they know
what a solar panel is they know what a
gas turbine is you actually know what
these things are so this is the latest
numbers from Lazard in my money these
are the best numbers but they're very
similar to the numbers say that world
resource institute put out of the
department of energy put out these are
these are pretty good numbers okay
unlevel eyes subsidized cost of
electricity point one you guys have been
studying this class levelized cost of
electricity is a terrible way to talk
about this stuff it's grossly
insufficient to task it's just the best
thing that we have to compare apples to
apples for real okay but it doesn't
include things like capacity factor
dispatch and the value of resilience and
and how contracts are made and you know
it doesn't talk about a bunch of stuff
much less subsidies but but still this
is a good way to think about it if
you're not at least familiar with these
numbers you will fail as an entrepreneur
promise you have to actually think about
the numbers and what the competitive
landscape and the power sector looks
like to be serious about this so a
couple of things first of all utility
scale solar cheap this is real utility
scale solar cheap and in fact keeps
getting cheaper the 2017 numbers are
going to be better than the 2016 numbers
there's a couple of points out there in
Abu Dhabi and Chile and Mexico where
people are putting unsubsidized power
purchase agreements in 43 cents kilowatt
hour that's awesome utility-scale solar
cheap something else you can see on the
same diagram rooftop solar not cheap
rooftop solar not close to cheap
actually rooftop solar wildly more
expensive okay also true and the range
is there are ranges as a function of
Technology a function of solar resource
a function of a number of things okay
next thing wind cheap wind is actually
really cheap we've had 25 years of
deployment that's been backed by a whole
bunch of subsidies and industry action
investments so forth but it's worked
wind is competitive basically in a good
market we've got a good wind resource
almost anywhere if you've got onshore
wind great if you got offshore wind not
so much offshore wind still pretty
expensive actually solar thermal same
thing solar thermal something we
definitely need something we definitely
want today not really competitive and in
fact if you don't have the thermal
storage in the molten salt then it's
really not competitive so these are good
places to say hey let's tuck in do some
research let's drop the costs and in
fact the Department of Energy spending a
lot of money trying to get that done as
our other groups around the world now if
you look at the other stuff a couple of
things jump out one still cheapest
option efficiency you should always be
talking efficiency for real it's not
free the cost for it efficiency are not
zero a lot of people like to pretend it
is or there's obviously negative cost
forever like not really no in some cases
there are but in some cases there's
market failures or capital expenses you
need upfront they're not zero but it's
the cheapest thing you can do and it's
the most effective and efficient on a
lot of reasons the thing that people
typically don't talk about is the bottom
part of the diagram first of all natural
gas combined cycle cheap almost
everywhere intensely competitive blows
almost all the other technologies out of
the water in almost every market so when
you're telling somebody don't burn
natural gas you're saying lose money for
a reason I can't defend that's a problem
if you actually want to reduce emissions
you have to answer that question better
coal in some place is cheap in some
places not cheap that's a function of
quality the coal financial cost a whole
bunch of other kinds of things but same
sort of thing in some markets cheap coal
will definitely beat cheap solar that's
an issue same issue I talked about
before this is part of the reason I do
what I do and there's you know I'm going
to talk about carbon capture and storage
and I will these are what the cost
looked like with carbon capture and
storage in them a couple of things one
in some markets those will be the
cheapest options just will be not in
every market in some markets second
point today the costs are competitive
with a bunch of stuff today the cost
actually beat offshore wind today the
cost everywhere they basically beat
nuclear almost everywhere the v8 rooftop
solar everywhere it is fair to ask then
why does nobody know what CCS is and why
isn't there any deployment because these
are actually true facts but that's not
representing the way we think about the
market or the way that we talk about the
market basically the reason why is a
policy question it is what we are
valuing and how we're valuing it I'm
going to spend a certain amount of time
talking about that here let me skip
through a couple of things here quickly
something that's true is costs are
really going down for a lot of the
renewables one of the things there's
also throughs it's not exactly clear
where that ends or how if you're an
entrepreneur think about this hard some
people like to look at the upper blue
arrow and say costs are going down
that's great kind of true some people
like to look at the dashed lines and go
costs aren't going down anymore at all
they kind of flattened out so we either
need a big technology breakthrough or
that's the add that other people look at
this and go why are those ranges so big
is there something we can do to shirt in
those ranges all of those things are
good questions to ask one thing that is
true about renewables and and I think is
sort of part of the reason they've been
so successful is that the pace of
innovation in renewables is very fast in
the reason why is because the capital
costs for a single solar panel or the
capital cost for a single windmill are
low you can build something for a few
hundred thousand bucks and test it out
try to make it better and try again
can't do that for a nuclear plant can't
do that for a coal plant can't do that
for ccs you need a billion dollars every
time you want to try that and it's hard
to get a billion dollars I've tried so
good things to know but again trying to
separate sense for nonsense yes the
prices are going down I think they
probably will continue to go down how
much to what end not obvious so thinking
about the value proposition in this
space you know good facts to know I'm
going to stop this part of the
presentation here and I am going to talk
just quickly about a couple of things in
the CCS space that are relevant and then
I'm going to go over to panel jeepers
stuffs hard let me blast through bunch
of this stuff because you've already
seen it and that's the truth let me
stalk about this one this is what the
power markets going to look like in the
United States there's a couple of this
is an analysis done by the Department of
Energy it's one that I like and
subscribe to one of them is the electric
cars sell fast and the other ones the
electric cars don't basically the high
electricity demand is one in which you
have an electric a lot of electric car
market penetration the other one is
basically flat where power demand stays
flat kind of for a long time one of the
things that's true in both of these is
that you actually get a lot of CCS in
both of them you get a lot of carbon
capture and storage and not just on coal
you'll also get it on gas part of the
reason why is because in some markets
CCS on gas is the cheapest option one of
the things that's true about this as
well is that the amount of CCS with
coal and gas is about the same and we
need a lot of it pretty soon in both of
these scenarios and again the reason why
is because if you don't have it cost
more in some market one of the ways I
like to explain this to people is in
California you probably won't use CCS I
personally hope we do I think there's
grounds to and so forth but we got great
solar resources we've got great wind
resources were an efficient economy
we've got a lot of support for other
kinds of things we've got maybe we won't
do that here compare that with Indiana
Kentucky Ohio no solar resource no wind
resource no geothermal resource bunches
of my mouth coal a lot of natural gas
supply in their backyards for them
that's not the right solution to go to
renewable economy a lot of people then
will say well we'll just transmit it in
will bring it all from the Dakotas will
build these huge transmission lines and
bring all the power that we need to and
then we'll back it up with batteries
well okay well when you bat back it up
with batteries you triple the capital
cost upfront for real you triple it
that's a lot of money and the
transmission costs money and you might
not build it are you really willing to
bet the planet on that I'm not so I
voted with my feet I spent a lot of my
time thinking about ccs and trying to
figure out how to make it work in the
world and the good news is that there's
a lot of it that does work in the world
this is a plant that's been operating
for 20 years in Norway we've put 20
million tons of carbon dioxide
underground there here's one in Canada
the weyburn plant this was actually from
an industrial facility in North Dakota
it's about at 20 million tons as well
about one and a half million tons a year
the world's first post combustion
retrofit power plant was built in Canada
three years ago its operating just fine
thank you they were operating at about a
million tons a year this is this is an
important thing they're retrofitting a
lignite plant okay the retrofitting a
low-ranked coal plant with a crappy old
boiler that's what they did here it was
actually their cheapest option in
Saskatchewan 20 out their carbon
footprint because Saskatchewan also has
no son and you can't harness the wind
resources because the wind is too strong
actually it destroys the capital you
invest
and there's a whole bunch of industrial
plants all over the world and they're
all work in just fine at the scale of
many millions of tons a year in fact the
ones that have been built in our
operating today put about 28 million
tons of carbon dioxide underground and
by the end of the decade the ones that
are under construction will have a total
of about 40 million tons a year that are
being captured and stored permanently or
it's a indefinitely so we know that this
works it's also worth noting that 10
countries list carbon capture and
storage as part of their NDC's it's part
of their contribution of the Paris
agreement and a number of countries like
China like the United States like
Australia and Canada don't mention CCS
but plan to do it if you want proof of
that the North American Accord that was
signed by Canada Mexico the United
States back in June of this year i think
june of this year say that they're going
to have fifty percent clean energy power
by 2025 clean energy power includes
large hydro nuclear and ccs all three of
those countries have said all of the
above is what they're going to do and
there's only one of these plants that I
want to show you it's relevant and I'm
going to they're gonna stop talking this
is a plant that's going to turn on in a
couple of weeks it's actually a hundred
percent built on time and on budget
all-in cost of carbon capture and
storage are about a hundred dollars a
ton okay and they've already said they
can build the second plant for 70 bucks
a ton all-in costs capture compression
transport and storage to give you some
sense of comparison spitballing the wind
production tax credit that's sixty
dollars a ton the energy venda in
germany is three hundred dollars a ton
well we're subsidizing for clean energy
in california is about 160 dollars a ton
so these plants are already cheaper than
those other things in the same ballpark
so again there's a market failure at
work here the fundamental issue here is
that there's no way to get your money
back if you build one of these plants I
have the good fortune of working with a
bunch of bankers and finance people
and people give bankers a hard time I
love bankers because they ask really
easy questions so I came to a bank and I
say I want a billion dollars and they
say we would love to give you a billion
dollars first question how are we going
to get our money back if you can't
answer that question you won't get a
billion dollars you won't build a plant
this is about financing ccss not too
expensive but you can't finance it today
and part of the reason you can't finance
it today you don't have a clean energy
portfolio standard you have a renewable
portfolio standard so States will
mandate a certain amount of renewables
but won't include CCS in that you have
investment in production tax credits for
wind and solar not available to
geothermal learn to clearer CCS or a
whole bunch of other clean energy
technologies ok so we've already made
some decisions about saying we want to
invest in a clean energy enterprise and
we want to support it but as a national
policy while we may talk all of the
above and understand all of the above is
valuable most states and Congress are
not actually pursuing all of the above
for real what they're saying is we like
this and when you say that you're
basically saying fine but just know that
you're not actually going to hit your
global climate targets you're not going
to create the clean energy economy the
future and you're not going to actually
you're going to end up spending more
money than you need so with that happy
idea I going to stop talking for a bit
and transfer back to Leslie to have
conversation
well that was a great and sobering intro
which chair would you like I don't care
okay so we're going to run this as a
mini panel imagine Cait here please do
for those of you who'd never met Kate or
hurt her she is awesome I have all the
time in the world for Kate and I'm
despondent and she's not able to join us
today yeah this was a true family
emergency back east there was no way
around it and she would love to be here
if she could and maybe we can work out a
way to do it later this quarter she at
least said she could write some answers
to some of the questions that you've
asked I thought that I would start
perhaps on some of the very Kate
specific questions that I had and you
will be our virtual Kate I'm your
virtual case okay what can I say so what
I what I am asking Julio and Kate are
the risky business reports are clear
well researched at alarming how much
attention have they received in
government California and us and have
they been used to help shape policy
first of all they've gotten a lot of
attention not the least reason that
you've got Tom Steyer George Shultz and
Bloomberg on writing this really they're
the ones who put it forward more and
people like to meet with billionaires
and they'd like to meet with George
Shultz that's all good and so these were
all taken very very seriously I will say
that these things are actually taken
more seriously in the boardroom than
they are taken in state legislatures the
reason why is because boards actually
own capital assets they actually
responsible to their shareholders they
have to make money so boards boards of
directors take this stuff very very
seriously it is also fair to then ask
how come they haven't made the
investment decisions because a lot of
boards haven't first of all watch this
space I think they're seriously doing it
the second of all a lot of the decisions
that you would like boards to make in
terms of investment decisions or
research directions or corporate
strategy and stuff are still not
rewarded in the market so they won't do
it and until that gets fixed it's on
there they are sort of waiting here
going we know exactly what to do
when this thing changes so we're going
to wait until this thing changes and
then we know exactly how to make our
money after that but but I can't
underscore the importance of these
reports they were actually very well
received and very influential and
anybody who's serious about this topic
has read them and appreciates the value
they've provided perfect and I'm
delighted to hear that there's more
attention than we would see by looking
at the headlines right okay it would
yeah so I was going to ask if not why
not what is getting in the way and
you've answered that very eloquently
what are the proper agencies to make
such policy decisions because the
policies will help the boardrooms make
their decision right so that's actually
kind of a tricky question the right
place to make these decisions is not in
any agency the right place to make these
decisions as in legislators you actually
need to pass laws this has this has not
necessarily worked perfectly everywhere
California is perfectly good at passing
laws they don't always make sense I like
to describe to people that we do a fire
ready aim in California and so one
example of this was the thirteen hundred
megawatt battery policy if you call the
utilities and say why are you putting up
thirteen hundred megawatts of storage
they will say because the legislature
told us I've actually had this
conversation with utility CEOs that is
in fact the answer they give us why 1300
why batteries at all what are you trying
to accomplish it's hard to answer these
questions but we've passed laws and part
of the reason maybe is to create an
industry for batteries part of the
reason is maybe to continue to push down
emissions by storing you know renewable
power when it's not going on but but in
fact that renewable mandate says nothing
about carbon in it the battery mandate
says nothing about carbon in it if the
goal is to reduce emissions you should
have a law that says something about the
emissions but that's not the way that we
do it the United States Congress is the
exact opposite 0 happening occasionally
you can squeak through an incentive
people like lollipops I like lollipops
if I if I had a choice as legislature I
would always give an incentive before
giving a punishment like a tax or
constraint or something like that
to be fair the policies work the same
you can give lots of carrots are lots of
sticks the work doesn't change the only
agencies that actually have authority
over this space or basically the air
agencies so the EPA California Air
Resources Board groups like them have
the authority to act in this space so
the question is what do they do in
California were blessed by having Mary
Nichols as a executive director as the
chair chairman of the California Air
Resources Board she's awesome awesome
awesome and one of the things she knows
is that she really wants to reduce
pollution and she doesn't want to do it
in a way that's kind of productive so
her team is excellent they work really
really hard they're very careful about
the rules they make but when they make a
rule they're confident they're making
the right decision and they're trying to
make it work well and listen to lots of
people them to take a lot of advice and
they really work it hard they think hard
about the science the technology the
engineering the finance they think about
it all and then they try to make a good
wool in the case of the EPA first of all
of course we're whipsawed by national
politics that aren't exactly good be the
EPA only has so many things it can do
and so they try their best and what
they've come up with I would say is not
a perfect solution by any means they I
think they would accept that but also
say we have to pass something that
passes jurisprudence we also have to do
our best to reduce pollution and we are
well within our jurisdiction to do such
things all of those statements are true
they are also open to amending it most
of their regulations of a process by
which every six years or eight years or
ten years they can amend it so they
gather data they are a fact-based
institution to gather data try to
understand what the regulation means and
then try to amend it the point of fact
you really need legislators to sort this
out okay great and then could you
describe Kate's work at next generation
in the Paulson Institute and what's what
are the Continuum's of what she's doing
and let's change sure so a couple of
things first of all she's the vice
president Paulson Institute Paulson
Institute's terrific started by Hank
Paulson Hank Paulson is actually also
one of the risky business partners Hank
was george bush's secretary of the
Treasury so he knows things about stuff
especially in the money sector and in
particular he said I care about China if
and I care about climate so the Paulson
Institute has now for a long time been
focusing on climate issues and China
issues and China and climate issues so
I'll certain amount of what kate is
doing there is actually thinking about
how to engage in climate issues with the
business community and and how to affect
change in China in a useful way and
again you can't be cavalier about that
it turns out Hank Paulson and Xi
Jingping or two different people and
they have a different brief so but but
the idea is there is still useful work
to do and a lot of what the Paulson
Institute spends its time thinking about
is what constitutes useful action same
thing with next gen next gen is really
based on US politics they're trying to
figure out how do we build
constituencies how do we change policies
how do we elect people who will care
about these things and so forth but
really that's activism in the United
States and advocacy in the United States
but it's still a hard question to ask
answer what constitutes useful action
next gen has done better than a lot of
groups actually in answering that
question well and trying to effect
change whether it's through dialogue
with state legislators or with corporate
boards there were shareholder actions by
helping elect candidates who they think
care about climate for real and what I
make change all these other sets of
things they try to cast it in the
perspective of risk to children that's a
good thing to do they try to cast in the
perspective of the human health issues
also a good thing to do again I have a
lot of positive things to say about
next-gen and a lot of the reason why
both of these groups have been so
effective is because Kate remains
awesome I've got two last cake questions
that are from students and then perhaps
we'll ask for a couple of more Kate
questions here and then dr. Friedman can
turn back into Julio yes so so one of
them was according to the risky business
report their significant financial cost
to agriculture coastal property and
infrastructure and increasing energy
prices due to climate change if this is
the case why don't we see more
corporations proposing plans to mitigate
the effects or lobbying the government
motivated by their fiduciary duty so
aside humanitarian reasons so there's a
couple of reasons why why that's the
case first of all like I said boards are
actually taking this seriously there's a
group called series I don't know if
you're familiar with him CER es their
environmental advocacy group that
basically works with banks and boards
and one of the things that they've done
recently was they had a big stake holder
it was our big shareholder vote at
chevron and Exxon and their request was
kind of modest they said we want you to
explain to us the shareholders how
you're taking climate change into your
long-term financial planning in
corporate strategy the companies that
they worked with Chevron and Exxon
unquestionably have very sophisticated
long-term finance and climate strategies
they don't share those with the public
it is reasonable to ask well maybe you
should share that and people can go back
and forth about that but that's kind of
a good way to effect change but but the
reason basically boils down to well
what's the financial return really
that's that that is what the policy
decision is about the policy decision
about who gets paid that's it and to a
lesser extent how much you get paid
that's what the policy decisions in the
Energy Climate space really are about
and until that happens a board will look
there and say well like why should we be
hardening coastal infrastructure really
like that's that's the job of a refinery
I don't think so we will harden our
refinery because that's an asset that's
owned by the shareholders and it
generates money for the company I'm
going to go call the eight no no it's
just my this is my computer where to
sleep that's oh oh oh that's it we can
we get up with you two but yeah maybe we
can make sure that some that the picture
is projecting here but until that
actually happens there's no reason for
them to do such a thing it is also true
and really true that corporate boards do
not like to go to government and push
policy they're really don't there's two
good reasons why they don't like to do
that there's other reasons but there's
two good reasons that they don't want to
do that one of them is that no company
wants to build a business model on a
government policy they will be
responsive to a government policy but
they really don't want to be sitting
here saying I
I want to build a business on something
that a bunch of guys outside of our
company decide on they would rather let
the market do it and be competitive in
the market the second thing about it is
people will say well how come Exxon and
Chevron and these other companies are
you know Peabody how come they're not
going to government asking for change
the answer to that's pretty obvious what
would happen if you had a whole bunch of
fossil energy companies going to
Congress and saying we want you to pass
this legislation whatever it was they
recognize that it's unseemly to actually
be asking for anything to be asking for
a level playing field to be asking for a
set of subsidies any of these other
things so they're actually highly
reluctant to do it and once the law
passes they will be highly responsive
and they'll be good corporate citizens
in every way but until that time happens
they're not there it's hard for them to
decide to go to Congress one of the
useful conversations to have is to say
you should talk to policymakers anyways
you should be proactive in this space
because you can't afford not to be
proactive the riskier company faces is
too great if you're not actually
proactive and talk about some policy
solutions but I understand why it's hard
for these guys to walk that walk there's
one last and that is for Kate if you had
the power but you should answer this too
if you had the power to design and
implement the clean energy policy for
the next ten years in the US how would
you do it to satisfy the extreme
environmentalists and the coworkers
first of all that's not the job the job
is not to satisfy these guys we have a
conversation today which is dominated by
the ends of the dumbbells and that's
just not helpful what I would say is
instead what is something that gets the
job done that everyone can live with I
actually don't have to make pill Bill
McKibben happy or the CEO of peabody
happy i don't but we do have to get
emissions down there's two basic ways to
think about the policy one that is real
and will work and the other which is
probably the right way to do it but
won't ever happen that second one is the
carbon tax there's only one country in
the world that has a carbon tax it's
Norway it's a city of four million it's
a country of four million people with a
huge sovereign wealth plan
and ninety-eight percent hydropower you
can't really put a carbon tax into any
other country and it hasn't worked and
the primary reason why is because it
automatically it disadvantages you in a
bunch of ways so a lot of people said
let's have a global carbon taxes like no
like that's not going to happen we tried
that for two decades and failed we can't
even get a carbon tax in this country we
can't get a gas tax in this country to
fix the roads I mean so the idea that
we're going to even even though it may
be the most economically efficient thing
to do I don't think it's effective
because it doesn't exist a unicorn may
be the best mode of transportation but
I'm not going to call one on the phone
to get from here to home so the thing
that's effective and the thing that
people do do is they set emission limits
we don't have a price on sulfur but
we've reduced sulfur emissions in this
country by ninety percent we had a cap
and we ratcheted it down that's the
policy that I personally like I would
not recommend it as a deal we employee I
would not recommend it as Lawrence
Livermore National Security employee
because we don't recommend policy but
there are advantages to an emission
standard one of all you make it big
eleven hundred pounds per megawatt hour
or you know a comparable thing for the
cement and steel industries make it
economy-wide start it 15 years start at
a ways out so everybody has time to
develop research to implement the
technologies to buy the equipment to
figure out their business to do a bunch
of stuff but make it down make it big
and make it binding and then ratchet it
further every five years you drop
another 200 pounds per megawatt-hour
that would actually make it economy-wide
and it would make it equitable if you do
that you need to pull away all the other
subsidies need to pull away whether its
wind and solar investment production tax
credits or land access for mining you
have to sort of get rid of all of it and
say the only thing we care about is down
make it big and make it binding and the
market will respond to that but if you
want to get GE to put 300 million
dollars a year into a technology they
need to think the markets there and if
they don't have that signal they won't
put that money into it you have a
question when you sit be a you met feet
you didn't
start higher than who I so you actually
have to start up I think below and
uncontrolled coal plant if you don't do
that we're not reducing emissions this
is a perfect time to ask are there any
more risky business questions before we
go a little more general but but I do
want to say again though I'm not
recommending this policy I'm not I don't
make policy and in the past I've had the
good fortune to recommend policy to
people who do I've advised members of
Congress a lot of sort of sting and
given my own ideas but it is not it is
outside my purview to recommend policy
I'm not doing it today so I think I'll
start on you okay with student questions
and then take mine later does anybody
have a burning question for dr. Friedman
before I go to the ones that were sent
in yes a carbon capture and storage
issue that you showed you should plants
that do tens of millions of tons of
carbon capture storage per year but what
we need to do is billions not millions
right okay tens of billions right and so
we're along a long way from that is most
of that carbon capture and storage
pumping the co2 underground is that what
most of that is that is what all of that
is what all of that is so we're not
talking about terrestrial sequestration
we're not talking about biochar we're
not talking about a forestation we're
not talking about these things this is
just there was a smokestack it was
pointing up now it's pointing down
that's all we're talking about so first
of all I guess you're right we haven't
deployed much 40 40 million tons a year
by 2020 is a good number but it is not
four billion so a couple of thoughts to
that in that context the deployment for
ccs is about where the deployment of
solar and wind were 20 years ago right
second of all there's no technical
barriers doing it so and in fact the
cost will come down and continue to come
down there are learning curves for
renewables
of all kinds there's also learning
curves for fossil and the you ultimately
work your way down those learning curves
through deployment the other thing that
I would say is the international energy
agency has been very clear about this to
hit a 2050 target you need a hundred
times more than we have today not a
million times more but you do need a
hundred times more that is a big number
it is also true that seventy percent of
that is going to be in non-oecd
countries right so we have to figure out
how to how to do this in a way that
those countries would actually adopt and
embrace which is not an easy thing to do
either it is also worth knowing that the
OE that the International Energy Agency
says about half that deployment will not
be in the power sector it'll actually be
heavy industry it'll be cement it'll be
steel it'll be glass it'll be
petrochemicals and refining it'll be
fertilizer plants ethanol plants these
things I made a huge amount of co2 and
these things have very very few
alternatives even if you could make a
solar smelter like a solar steel plant
which nobody knows how to do at this
point even if you could when you make
steel you release carbon dioxide when
you make cement you release carbon
dioxide it's in the chemistry of the
process so if you're not capturing and
storing those emissions you don't zero
out those emissions so you actually need
to do a lot of this in the industrial
space as well as in the power sector
this is a good time to ask one of the
student questions a few weeks ago dr.
Brent Constance told us that co2 had
essentially no value once captured how
do you think alternatives to ccs that
produce useful products compared to
classic ccs right so a couple of things
first of all that statement is not when
I agree with there is actually a big
active commodities business today in co2
sales we inject a hundred million tons
of carbon dioxide underground this year
and it's bought and traded on the open
market it was almost entirely almost
entirely for the purpose of enhanced oil
recovery so if you don't have an oil
field that can take the co2 for enhanced
oil recovery you can't really sell into
that market it's not a global solution
but to say it has no value today is
flatly and correct second of all we
choose to value these things or not
there's a two bills in front of Congress
right now one in the house and one of
the Senate which would basically create
something like a production tax credit
for carbon capture and storage the House
version would be 30 bucks a ton the
Senate version would be 35 bucks a ton
for enhanced oil recovery and fifty
bucks a ton for storage if that's the
case certainly would not have zero value
at that point you could go to a bank and
say I'm storing a million tons of co2 a
year that means that we'll have a five
million 50 million dollar a year revenue
stream and it will come in the form of
this investment tax credit that is not
true today that is factually correct but
it sometime after November 9th that may
actually be true and these are policy
decisions to say it doesn't have a value
is correct but it's also a policy choice
third thing is we actually really do
need better technologies for co2
utilization right now we have enhanced
oil recovery that's kind of it we would
like to turn co2 into useful products
rocks that works cement that can work
right now we can turn co2 into algae the
problem is at the end of the day you've
got algae which isn't exactly a big
commodity you can use it maybe as an
animal nutrient you can use it for fish
food you can use it to maybe upgrade to
biofuel someday all this the economics
of algae are very hard speaking of which
I have to say in a few weeks we're going
to have a startup then how makes biofuel
bio produce sugars using algae so great
so it's not crazy but but the economics
are very very hard turning co2 into
almost anything else is crazy from a
thermodynamics perspective but we still
need it co2 is spent fuel turning it
into anything else means you're putting
in more energy and you got out of it in
the first place the second law of
thermodynamics is a harsh mistress don't
let anyone tell you otherwise but we're
still going to need it we actually are
going to need zero carbon fuels to
reduce the footprint in the
transportation sector because there's
some things that are just hard to scrub
it's hard to scrub jet planes it's hard
to scrub a train specific shipping there
are parts of the transportation
heavy-duty vehicles are hard to zero out
their missions profile so we're actually
going to need a truly net zero carbon
neutral fuel maybe that will be biofuels
maybe not but we actually need zero
carbon drop in liquid fuels to a couple
of people here at Stanford have put
forward the idea that when solar and
wind is two cents a kilowatt hour at
that point it makes economic sense to
upgrade into fuels there's a bunch of
assumptions baked into that but it's not
crazy to think that it's also not crazy
to think that we might actually live in
a world soon that has to centra Newell's
so there's work to be done as
entrepreneurship to be had don't mistake
that though for what the market actually
is today today in the market if you if
it cost you ten dollars a gallon to make
a zero-carbon footprint fuel no one will
buy that so you have to work these
things through so sort of following up
on this economists tell us that we need
to price carbon however the most
successful policies on ghd's to date
seem to be subsidies wind and solar ITC
ibtc and mandates state RPS federal air
pollution requirements even in
California the policy that seems to be
making a difference as the RPS not the
cap-and-trade system how can we make the
transition from robust carbon pricing
schemes which our opponents may
legitimately label is a hidden over text
right in part I kind of don't care again
I'm kind of a policy agnostic I just
want it to work I want the number i want
the numbers to go down I care about tons
if you go to the California Legislature
and you ask almost anybody there why are
you passing these climate and energy
laws almost always they will say because
we need to reduce emissions I've run
this experiment it's true and they
actually really care about greenhouse
gas emissions but like i said before
they don't actually have an emissions
contingent in the law so instead it's
percent of market penetration or
something like that or it's a subsidy
for electric vehicles or rooftop solar
it's some other thing with the hope that
that will reduce emissions part of the
reason why is because it's a lot easier
to be Santa Claus than to be dad and
it's a lot easier to get reelected if
you're Santa Claus and if your dad so
when I tell my children
got to clean their rooms their responses
were predictable I tell my kids you got
to clean your room and they say no I
don't my room is fine we did that for 30
years that's what the past 30 years of
climate discussion is but I don't need
to clean my room this isn't real then I
say no you still got to clean your room
what are my kids do they go into the
room and they play with their favorite
toys that's what we're doing now is a
world it helps maybe maybe they'll pick
up their favorite toys and put them on
the shelf but you can't confuse that
with cleaning your room at some point or
another clean cost more clean cost more
for acid rain clean cost more for
mercury clean cost more for particulates
those were relatively cheap costs
compared to not clean but in point of
fact it costs more the costs have come
down a lot there's markets around those
if people who've end these stuff there's
heavy industries around them that's all
good but clean costs more you shouldn't
expect that there's a zero cost to this
part of the value of risky business is
to say there's a really big cost for not
doing this in the same way that if my
kids don't clean their room there's a
big cost so I don't have a good answer
for how to go about this for real I
don't but I I think it's important to
focus on the outcome you care about and
for me deploying more renewables is a
helpful outcome but not the same thing
as reducing tons this sort of follows on
the same thing as you may know Stanford
has recently had a fairly strong divest
from fossil fuels student movement do
you believe such movements and this one
in particular effective what's the most
effective way for college students to
influence climate and energy ah to be
young uh it is not clear to me that I
remember well by the way it is not clear
to me that a divestment strategy will be
effective in this space there's grounds
to believe it might it is not clear to
me that it will be part of the reason
why is because the investment community
has already kind of voted with their
feet on a lot of this stuff they're not
investing in new coal mines and new coal
builds they're not investing in in heavy
oils as much a lot of
groups have already divested from those
things so and pushing in the
universities hold on these is relatively
small is a compared to something like
CalPERS you know which is huge I think
if you want to effect change there's a
few things that are helpful to do I
actually think the strategy that series
pursues the one that I talked about
before is more effective because as a
shareholder you actually have a say in
to what a company does so affecting a
shareholder action is I think a very
effective way to go about it and those
shareholder votes Chevron was forty
percent of the shareholders said we want
you to show us are your climate and
energy plan at Exxon thirty-eight
percent of the shareholders said its
climate and energy plan so it is fair to
say that they were unsuccessful but
you're the CEO of Chevron you listen to
that you really do and so they're
looking at those tea leaves and saying
well what do we do how do we figure out
what's useful to our shareholders right
now but they have to be responsive to
their shareholders I think that's
actually rather than a divest strategy I
like a invest strategy invest in clean
energy invest in policies that help make
the transition invest in companies that
you think have a successful business
model investing companies that currently
admit to try to get them to change the
practice I think again for the same
reason that we like incentives carrots
are better than sticks if you can
provide an incentive to two companies
and boards to make a better decision
than they will want to do it think i'm
going to turn to you folks do you have
any burning questions here more coal
plants a you use ccs how much does that
increase the amount of coal you need
four units electricity there is no easy
answer to that question and let me
unpack the many ways in which there's no
easy answer to that question first of
all the way that this is typically
calculated is the opposite it is you
used no more cold and D rate your power
plant okay it turns out that's not the
way it's actually done in the world but
that's the way that most of this
calculus is done which is why most of
this calculus gets the wrong number
compared to what's actually deployed the
numbers that are actually deployed are
cheaper second of all
it is highly contingent on the quality
of the cold the age of the plant the
heat rate of the boiler the conversion
process the capture technology a whole
bunch of things so we always at the
Department of Energy present these
things as ranges because there are
ranges around all these things second of
all it actually turns out to be very
sensitive to your local geography in the
case of the boundary dam plant there
they put in a new boiler that was more
efficient to generate and and Jared more
steam and they are using more coal but
the amount of extra colder we're using
is smaller because they used a bigger
better boiler okay but there is more
coal that went into that for sure the
all-in costs there are about one hundred
twenty seven dollars tonne so still
competitive for in bunch of markets more
than you'd like to pay if you didn't
have to at the petranova plant
sub-bituminous coal higher efficiency
project and the process heat they're
using does not come from coal it comes
from natural gas there is they added
natural gas supply to provide the
process heat which has a lower carbon
footprint and lower costs good business
model so these things end up being in
case in point very specific to it to a
plant into an energy type and all these
other sorts of things I also think that
it's not really a helpful discussion
disabled aren't you're going to use more
coal as far as I'm concerned a fossil
energy is great except for the
greenhouse gas emissions we've figured
out how to zero out everything else well
but but the thing is I mean it's cheap
it's ubiquitous it's easy to transport
it's safe it is a it is energy storage
in a very real way out in front of a
coal plant you have three months of
energy in a pile and and we needed that
actually for example during the what was
it that that event a couple of years ago
that the winter that we had this massive
event in twenty annuaire e 2015 where
the polar vortex where the polar vortex
came down all of the power plants and
everywhere and in the North America just
turned on and ran all the time
so so there's their ends up being valued
of these things so I think it's
important to separate the fuel from the
emissions the emissions from fossil
energy are pretty bad actually if you
don't control the sulfur if you don't
control the particulates if you don't
control the mercury the emissions are
pretty awful that's why most parts of
the world don't have de kenzi and coal
plants anymore we've actually controlled
all those things and that's pushed some
of those two shot a lot of the coal
plant closures in North America have
been because of the mercury standards
not because of the carbon standards and
I have no problem with a clean coal
plant except for the co2 emissions you
want those co2 emissions to get as close
to zero as you can if you can then that
should be clean energy no clean megawatt
left behind and so if in fact you
produce more oil or produce more coal
yeah those have local impacts those
local impacts are real maybe on the
safety of the miners maybe on the beauty
of the environment maybe on the health
of the ecosystem those are also costs
that you should internalized but but
there's not necessarily anything
inherently bad in any fuel and I think
that's troll for nuclear fuel as well
there's nothing inherently bad with
nuclear fuel there's nothing inherently
bad with nuclear power but there are
things you got to manage and if those
management issues mean you're not
competitive at the end of the day that's
a different story what asked what did
you learn and what did you teach during
your time in Washington you're very much
in favor of taking a turn in government
and would you advise others to do so and
under what circumstances right so I
deeply enjoyed my time in Washington I
really did it's not just cuz it's a fun
town what it is first of all I learned
an immense amount there's just no
comparison to what you learn inside the
tent from outside you just see things
that you wouldn't see otherwise and you
learn things you wouldn't learn
otherwise so also second of all everyone
I worked with was awesome almost to a
fault very few exceptions to that one of
my favorite examples is the deputy air
director for
EPA just incredibly hard-working
incredibly knowledgeable incredibly good
at his job and seeing these people toil
you know 60 hour weeks you know for
what's relatively modest pay and just
getting punched in the face every day
you know Joe Kaufman is a national
treasure you know and getting to meet
these people and see and work with these
people including the staff that I work
with the deal we including the staff I
didn't work with the deal we these
people are awesome and touching that is
terrific third I had the great fortune
in the capacity that I had to have a
global impact two of the president's
budgets had proposed incentives for ccs
they would not have if I wasn't in
Washington it was a team effort a lot of
people put it in but but being there
helped make a difference at one point
somebody came down to the annual
Christmas party and told me we need to
write something up for the president
he's having breakfast with the secretary
tomorrow he asked question about ccs
knowing that that's part of the job was
intensely helpful i was able to
represent the US government in india and
china all over europe and canada and
mexico and talk about issues of material
importance and i learned a bunch from
that and i gained incredible respect for
the people who i met and worked with and
the need and how they go about their
business and and at the end of the day I
just loved it I hope that if the
circumstances are right again that I
have an opportunity to serve again and
make no mistakes its service there are a
lot of times you're like wow this thing
I have to do is really stupid it is
going to take a huge amount of time but
I don't get to say no I'm going to do
this because that's what's required
there's a bunch of times where it was
like hey you thought you were going to
wave this weekend but you're not you
thought you were sleeping this evening
you're not but but but that's again part
of the nature of service and I felt
really fortunate to have the opportunity
to do so and again hope under the right
circumstances to do so again very cool
the public debate on climate change
seems highly polarized and politically
driven despite the partisanship or
various government agencies willing to
collaborate in an effort to combat
climate change our funding decisions for
climate change research generally
data-driven
or do politics play a large role it will
come as a shock to all of you to hear
that there's politics in Washington in
fact this was the only one I learned one
and only one big thing in Washington DC
which is the politicians are good at
politics they are good at politics the
way that I'm good at Geoscience or
aluminum daar is good at material
science and engineering it's like like
they are good at their job you know
whether you're not you agree with their
policies you know Harry Reid and Mitch
McConnell are not chumps they are good
at what they do one of the things I
learned from this is if you can't tell a
story that helps these people get to yes
in a political context nothing happens
so part of the job actually has to be to
figure out what matters to these guys
that's important it's really important
one example of this that I can point to
is in 2010 there was a whole bunch of
people trying really really hard to pass
a climate bill there were two Senate
Democrats who voted against it at the
end of the day so they didn't get the
cloture so it didn't happen the vote
ended up being sort of 58 242 2m though
the two people who didn't vote were kent
conrad and byron Dorgan who were both
Democrats in North Dakota North Dakota
is a state that's seventy percent
Republican there were the two senators
when I say very heavy and fossil energy
in oil and gas and coal they just
couldn't do it politically and let me
also say that if the somebody had put a
sixty thousand dollar ad buy in the
Bismarck Tribune things might have
changed but you have to talk to these
guys in a way that is respectful and
rational and helpful if you don't do
that you don't make the progress you
need it is also fair to say that you can
do a lot within that context one of the
things that please me a great deal is
that the Senate staffers really know
their business well the governor the
government apparatchiks the people who
are the lifetime civil servants really
know their business well really well and
they play together pretty nicely
actually even when they don't agree they
will sit across from each other a table
have respectful conversations and try to
figure out how to make progress because
everybody knows that they want to make
progress nobody goes to Washington to do
nothing they all went there to make
change to pass laws to make the world a
better place and so there's an
opportunity and talking to them and
working with anybody who's there whether
their congressional staffer whether
there's some flunky at the White House
whether they are a civil servant to the
Department of Treasury you know these
guys are actually the people who get the
work done and they're really really good
at their jobs and they know a lot so I
think it's very helpful to be positive
and proactive and engage with them to
ask a lot of questions to go in there
with one mouth in two ears and to really
try to figure out to turn your intellect
in your experience into something that's
helpful to these guys so they can make
helpful policy that keeps the nation
going perfect any more questions from
the audience yes what a small point um
hedda stable with comparing prices per
kilowatt hour for business obviously
when it comes to nuclear energy into the
part that with it on that on that back
because you have an almost infinite
fixed costs and a zero marginal costs
even if actual happens that fixed costs
next up to infinity but then i'd like to
press you more on the green they're
going to put issue of carbon tax on the
one hand you seem to have great
confidence in the commitments made by
these parents by all these nations were
they as I see it again he retracted
presidential orders however we're not a
party in power and all that was not our
commitment there was a previous
committed you seem to have big awfulness
in that solving on the other hand
something that is universal like a
carbon tax you don't see any place for
it and it seems to be like an admission
that he cannot avoid the tragedy of the
Commons
that basically became up price the
comments the attempt is being made and
it's a the Washington to pass a carbon
tax and disagreement as to whether the
Sicilian other tax in addition to the
existing thanks for the the CEO club
once of all kinds of new investments and
so forth that the Kremlin fax avoids the
the things that you mentioned such as
subsidy for our building and our
electric power storage whether or not
there's any reduction in co2 legend said
for a second Iseman is all are leaving
on an electric car if you have something
that looks like the true cost of the
skull of the leavin her missions and
that whole industry reactant and they'll
not specifically going to be getting out
to small groups that would seem to be
more beneficial right so we have a lot
of experience with carbon tax and I want
to speak to that first then speak more
broadly and maybe closed their first of
all Kevin Rudd campaigned on a carbon
tax in Australia was elected passed a
carbon tax his successor Tony Abbott
undid the carbon tax campaigned on the
same issue his only issue was I'm going
to come into office i'm going to remove
the carbon tax which is exactly what he
did when he got into office second of
all we've just seen a carbon tax appear
in canada actually Justin Trudeau was
able to get a whole bunch of people
around a table and say we're gonna do a
carbon tax started small I think ten
bucks a ton or something like that but
with the desire to ratchet up by 2032
something substantive I think the number
was about 40 bucks a ton that sounds
useful maybe that will hold maybe it
won't maybe that will be pulled back
maybe that will do enough maybe it won't
okay but there's actually an object out
there you can point to and say alright
well there's at least one carbon tax
that came in recently and it looks like
maybe some good things will come from it
because it's the right direction and
about the right magnitude okay but I
want to be clear about this I don't
think there's anything magical about any
of these approaches
when I've had this discussion with
economists and once we get past our
talking points we basically both agree
the real issue is how do you internalize
the externality there's many many many
different ways to internalize the
externality economists like an economy
wise tax because it is the least
distorting in the market is the most
efficient politicians like at the least
because it's the hardest thing to get
across the finish line and it's not that
I like one versus the other the reality
is it's very very hard to get such a
thing put put back again to say that
right now there's only two countries in
the world that have it so and if you
look at a country like Saudi Arabia they
would never do such a thing but they
have a huge sovereign wealth maybe they
can use that sovereign wealth to do good
things but they're not going to do it in
the form of a carbon tax as long as they
internalize that cost as long as they
spend the money as long as they reduce
their emissions I don't care one of the
things that's nice about Paris and let
me be clear about this I don't
necessarily have a lot of faith in the
Paris will be accomplished either and
laid out my caveats on the screen I
think it's an important event I think it
really matters to have 197 countries
acknowledge that climate change is
dangerous and at 2 degrees is the limit
we should shoot for that is a huge huge
deal and the fact that every country had
to pony up a plan matters a great deal
to China does not put is not necessarily
pursuing a carbon tax but they do have a
carbon market they will deploy two
hundred thousand megawatts of solar two
hundred thousand megawatts of wind a
hundred thousand megawatts of hydro and
eighty thousand megawatts a nuclear
that's hot it's all good you know that's
their contribution none of that's carbon
tax but it will avoid their emissions
growth and it will explore policy
options and try a bunch of things that's
part of the genius of Paris everybody
gets to choose their own way I am tired
of people coming to me and say my way is
the only way that works eat your peas
there's three ways to lose weight you
can eat less you can change your diet
you can exercise okay eat unless is
conservation and efficiency that works
maybe you could do that with a carbon
tax maybe you can do that with
see standards maybe you can do that with
some efficiency mandate a car
economy-wide I don't know you'd do it
but that actually loses weight you can
do it by changing your diet eat less
carbs eat more fruit wonderful that's
renewables that's biofuels it's a whole
bunch of other things you're changing
your diet okay that works too you can
exercise in my mind that's carbon
capture and storage same calories
they're just going somewhere else to be
peace for some other purpose I talk this
way because recently i've loose lost 35
pounds and i'm very pleased with this
and the way that I did it is I did all
those things and I'm still going to the
gym because you can't stop going to the
gym once you start right so I've eaten
less and I've changed my diet and I'm
exercising and guess what the pounds go
off and stay off but you know I don't
want anybody telling me what I will eat
how I will exercise and how I'm going to
accomplish my personal health goals
that's my choice and there's lots of
different ways to accomplish it any last
burning question here that's it that's
an inspiring and done thank you so much
for being
you